bueno en lo que estamos viendo ahorita
es que las pandemias trabajando en el
momento que bajan la cantidad de virus y
casos que nosotros tenemos igual que el
de la serie del 20 al 21 del 21-22 está
pasando lo mismo con tenemos una
minivacaciones generalmente entre marzo
y agosto pero hay que recordar que el
virus no se ha ido y se tiene y se tiene
que utilizar definitivamente barreras
cuando hay casos altos en la localidad
por tanto podríamos seguir viendo un
retorno cíclico quizás de estas medidas
durante el otoño y el invierno europeos
desgraciadamente así lo hemos visto y va
a continuar esta tendencia de que vamos
a tener que un estilo y afloje con las
medidas de salud pública para poder
salvaguardar definitivamente a nuestra
comunidad al momento que nosotros
tenemos menos casos podemos hacer más
cosas y definitivamente el hecho que
estemos quitando este mal tipo de
mandatos a nivel internacional no quiere
decir que el virus ya dejó de pegarnos
de hecho estamos viendo repuntes algunos
países por eso hay que tener cuidado
tener la mascarilla y todos modos
poniéndonos las vacunas cuando aún no
las tenemos y hablando de vacunas la
medida llega acompañada del fin de la
exigencia del pasaporte vacunación es
posible que esta medida sea eliminada
también de los viajes internacionales a
medio o largo plazo o se quedará con
nosotros
la realidad es que probablemente si los
casos que se trabajar puedan llegar a
exigir en ciertos países este tipo de
vacunación pero lo importante aquí es va
mucho más allá de los mandatos la vacuna
está hecha y diseñada para poder
disminuir la cantidad de personas que
terminan con complicaciones kobe
prolongado y sobre todo también con la
muerte entonces el hecho de no tener por
ejemplo las dos vacunas y el booster
está por esa vacuna extra que nosotros
no estamos realmente disminuyen la
posibilidad que nosotros nos defendamos
contra el virus pues el hecho que no
haya mandado todos tanto para la
mascarilla o por la vacuna eso no nos
redime para que nosotros tenemos todas
las guardias y bajemos definitivamente
la defensa y usted como especialista ve
que esta medida puede ser entonces parte
también de una estrategia de campaña
electoral porque recordemos que el
presidente manuel macro no aspira a la
reelección en abril
prácticamente todos los países que están
teniendo una disminución de casos están
tomando medidas semejantes lo importante
es ver qué está pasando en los
hospitales casos nuevos y muy importante
en la parte de mortalidad y si las
vacunas que nosotros tenemos siguen
defendiendo nosotros si estas cuatro
factores siguen funcionando pues podemos
hacer un poquito más laxos con las
medidas de salud pública pero importante
recordar a todos que esto pase o naciera
flojo y probablemente en
agosto-septiembre volvamos a tener este
tipo de vacunas y comentarios de los
mandatos que a nivel internacional